TIM MURRAY: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Tim Murray.
I'm an engineer at Google on
the RenderScript team.
And we're here to talk about
writing high performance
applications with
RenderScript.
So first, I'd like to talk
about GPUs in general.
So in the past seven years or
so, GPUs have become useful
for a lot more applications
than
just traditional graphics.
And the reason for this is that
they have a lot of flops
and a lot of memory bandwidth
verses CPUs.
And so they're really good at
data parallel tasks that
happen to look sort
of like graphics.
And the market where this has
had the most adoption is in
high performance computing,
supercomputing, oil and gas,
things like that.
The current number one machine
on the top 500 is primarily
GPU based, for example.
And now in mobile, we're
starting to see these
programmable GPUs arrive
and become useful.
But before we go into mobile,
I want to talk a little bit
about a traditional
desktop, or server
architecture with a GPU.
So the first thing you'll notice
is that in terms of raw
computational throughput,
floating point, memory
bandwidth, things like that,
the GPU dominates the CPU.
It's got four times the
memory bandwidth.
It's got 10 to 15 times the
flop on a high end GPU.
However, there's a problem,
and that's
the PCI express bus.
The PCI express bus is something
that all your data
has to traverse in order to move
from the GPU to the CPU,
or vice versa.
And compared to the speed of
memory bandwidth on either
device, it's very slow.
So a lot of the work in porting
an application to the
GPU and desktop comes from
managing this data transfer
overhead, and only moving work
to the GPU when you can
actually amortize the cost of
moving data to the GPU.
In mobile, things look
very different.
The first thing you'll notice
is that the GPU and the CPU
are now in the same package.
They share a single pool
of physical memory.
So there's no more
PCI express bus.
That transfer time is gone.
However, this does mean that
because they share the same
pool of physical memory, the
GPU no longer has a number
bandwidth advantage.
And to further reduce the GPU's
advantage, its floating
point performance relative to
the CPU is now only about
three to four times faster.
We're not talking 10 to 15
times faster anymore.
We also may have additional
processors
available to us in mobile.
For example, you could have a
camera ISP that can do things
like color space conversion
or basic convolution, or
something like that.
And you may have a
programmable DSP
on your SoC as well.
And you may really want to
use these processors when
possible, because they're
relatively fixed function.
And they may provide very,
very good perf per watt.
So in terms of architecture,
mobile
versus desktop is different.
And it's different in more
than just the block
diagram ways, too.
Mobile has a lot of
architectural diversity.
In desktop you have two CPU
vendors, three GPU vendors.
In mobile you have
three CPU ISAs.
Within ARM, you have a number
of different ARM cores and
licensed ARM cores.
You have dramatically more
GPUs and GPU vendors.
And particularly within the GPU
space, the architecture of
these GPUs are very different
from one another.
If you look at a kind of desktop
GPUs, in broad strokes
they look mostly similar.
That's not true in mobile.
Some of them look very CPU like,
and have very small SIMD
widths, and things like that.
Others look more like
traditional desktop GPUs, and
then they have very wide
vector widths.
Others look sort of
like a pool of
fixed function hardware.
And additionally in mobile, and
you have concerns about
system resources.
The biggest two there are power
and thermal constraints,
which generally don't affect
you as much on desktop.
You also have issues like the
GPU may be busy rendering a
lot of pixels.
For example on a Nexux 10, we
have a 2560x1600 display,
which is equivalent to a 30
inch desktop monitor.
And we're trying to drive that
on the GPU with 80 gigaflops,
instead of over a teraflop.
And you may have additional
processors that you want to
use as well.
So our goal here is really to
develop high performance
applications for these wide
variety of SoCs without
sacrificing performance
portability.
Without guaranteeing that the
more you optimize for one SoC,
the worse you run on
certain other SoCs.
So our approach to solving that
is called RenderScript.
And RenderScript is our platform
for high performance
computing across different
hardware on Android.
So the first thing you'll notice
about the API is that
the API is focused
on the system.
You don't get a list
of devices.
You don't get a big collection
of device properties and have
to try to figure out
at run time which
device you should use.
The runtime handles
that for you.
You simply have a computation
that you want to run quickly,
and we will try to put that on
the best processor we can.
What this means is that this
gives developers a consistent
target that will run well
across any SoC.
We work with the SoC vendors and
get drivers for their GPUs
and DSPs, ISPs, whatever, and
have those available on
tablets and phones.
And this way, the runtime
knows about whatever
processors and capabilities
it can use.
It doesn't require the developer
to go in and may
call these decisions at run time
about an SoC it's never
seen before.
We've been influenced by other
data parallel run times,
obviously, but we've kind of
taken things in a very
different direction.
So at a very high level view,
we do look very similar to
some of these other data
parallel runtimes.
We write performance
critical kernels
in a C99 based language.
These kernels are distributed
with your application as
architecture independent
bit code.
We then JIT compile those at
run time to one or more
processor targets.
For example, we may compile them
to ARM D7A with Neon, and
we may compile them to, for
example on the Nexus 10, we
have GPU support in
the Mali-T604.
So we may compile to build a
CPU and GPU at run time.
We also reflect Java classes
for easy integration with
existing applications.
And what this means is
essentially that every time
you have a RenderScript file,
we generate a set of Java
classes that go with it, so that
you can control execution
of that without relying on
string based APIs, or having
to use JNI, or something
like that.
We also have kind of standard
resource management and
execution in our Java
API as well.
One thing I didn't mention
here is we also have a
collection of, they're called
script intrinsics.
Essentially these are built in,
very fast operations that
we can tune to specific
architectures very well.
And they're things like YUV
conversion, or convolution,
stuff like that.
Common operations you may use
very often, where you can get
a really significant speedup by
tuning very, very closely
to a particular piece
of hardware.
So let's go through some basic
RenderScript definitions.
The first thing to talk
about is the element.
So an element is essentially
a C type.
In this case, it's an INT.
So it can be a scalar type,
like an INT, it could be a
vector type, like an INT4,
Float 4, whatever.
We can also supports C
structs as elements.
So if you declare a struct in
your RenderScript file, we
will actually reflect an element
class for that, that
will be available to Java.
So you can use that from
your Java API directly.
So an element is not very
useful in and of itself.
So to actually make use of this,
we have allocations.
And allocations are collections
of a single type
of element in some
arrangement.
It could be 1D or 2D.
They have an x and y dimension,
and they have a
backing store.
And essentially, an allocation
is how you get data from Java
into RenderScript, so
it can be processed
by one or more kernels.
And an allocation has one other
important aspects, and
that is the type.
And the type is essentially the
size of the allocation,
along with the elements used
within that allocation.
And we use this for
two things.
First of all, we use it to do
safety checking on copies and
kernel launches, and things like
that, to make sure that
you don't try to copy an
allocation of floats onto an
allocation of chars, because
it won't fit.
Or a 5x5 allocation of INTs onto
a 3x3 allocation of INTs,
because it won't fit.
We also do type checking when
we launch kernels, to make
sure that the element type
past tense of the kernel
matches what the
kernel expects.
The other way we use types is
to control how much parallel
work actually gets launched
by a kernel.
And we'll get into this
more in a bit.
So this is a dot RS file, a
very basic dot RS file.
And in general, we refer to each
one of these dot RS files
as a script.
And a script is essentially
its own little world.
There's no linkage between
scripts, or
anything like that.
So every script is
self-contained.
And the first thing you'll
notice here is that the script
starts with two pragmas.
First we have the RS
language revision.
For now it's one.
It will be one for the
foreseeable future.
After that, we have a
Java package name.
And this is the package name
that we use for the reflected
classes from this script.
After that we have what looks
like a normal C99 global.
We call that a script
global because it is
local to the script.
And this will reflect a method
called set add val, which
takes an INT to Java.
So if you want to update this
add val global from Java, you
can do that.
After that we have a kernel, and
this kernel looks mostly
like a standard C99 function,
except it has this decorator
attribute kernel.
An attribute kernel is the new
kernel syntax we introduced in
API 17, and I highly recommend
you use that.
And essentially what this means
is the kernel has an
input value and an output.
Or an input type and
an output type.
And here the input type is an
INT, so we get an INT in.
And then we also get two UINT
32Ts, x and y, which are
coordinates within
the allocation.
And this function returns an
INT, so essentially what
happens is when we run this
kernel on a given allocation,
for every element in the
allocation, this function will
be executed.
And so at every particular
coordinate pair in the
allocation, the value of that
element at that location will
be passed to this function.
And then the return value from
this function will be written
to the output application.
So because this kernel has both
an in argument and a non
void return type, it reflects
a method called for each
underscore kernel.
Just kernel here because that's
the name of the function.
And for each kernel takes two
allocations, an input
allocation and an output
application.
If you didn't have INT in and
you simply had x and y, it
would only take the
output allocation.
And similarly, if it didn't
return an INT, but simply
returned void, it would not
need an output allocation.
So I want to talk a little bit
about a more complicated part
of the API where you can do
more advanced things.
And that is called
us script group.
And a script group allows
a group of kernels to be
executed as a single
Java call.
More specifically, this allows
a dag of kernels to be
executed as a single
function call.
And by passing this entire
workload to the driver as one
monolithic entity before we
actually run any part of that
workload, we can enable
all sorts of different
optimizations in the run time,
and in the compiler.
For example, we can actually
enable, like, parallel
execution across devices, or
tiling, kernel fusion, which
we'll get into in a minute.
We actually see some significant
speed improvements
today by using script
group versus
using individual scripts.
And in general, I highly
recommend that you see script
group as much as possible going
forward, because it is a
place where we're going
to spend a lot of time
optimizing.
So let's go through an example
of script group.
So here we have five kernels,
and essentially input is
passed to A, and output comes
from E. And then you have this
set of dependencies
in between.
And according to the semantics
of script group, the
intermediate state is not
visible to the user.
So all of these connections
between A and B and A and C,
et cetera, which would
normally be stored in
programmer managed allocations
are instead simply set up as
connections between these
kernels and the graph.
And what this allows us to do
is the runtime can either
create those allocations if
necessary automatically, or we
can optimize them away
if possible.
And so we can do things here
like, because there's no
dependence between B and C, we
could run B on the CPU and C
on the GPU if possible, or
something like that.
If we wanted to get more
advanced, if we have more
knowledge about the way the
kernels actually run and the
particular dependency
information between colonels,
we could potentially do
something like fusing B and D
into a single kernel.
And this way you could simply
take the results of some
portion of B, depending on how
much you actually need to run
at a time, and immediately start
running that on D. And
this is potentially really good
for GPUs, and also really
good for CPUs, because it allows
you to use things like
local memory on the
GPU, and keep your
cache hot on the CPU.
So I'm going to talk about some
features coming up in an
upcoming release.
And the first feature we will
talk about this is the
compatibility library
for gingerbread.
And I'll go into that in a lot
more detail in a minute.
Other than that, we've added
rsSetElementAt, which
essentially is scatter support
for RenderScript.
You can now write arbitrary
allocations
from a given kernel.
We have debug runtime, which
does things like bounce
checking and prints out errors
to make it easier
to debug your code.
We've added more script
intrinsics, things like 3D
look up tables, and I think
something else.
We have native support for YUV
allocations, so you can take a
YUV allocation directly from a
camera, and process that in
RenderScript.
We've also improved launch
latency significantly.
So, the compatibility library.
The compatibility library
enables API 18 RenderScript on
devices running Gingerbread
or higher.
And the way this works is
essentially we can do an
offline compilation of your
RenderScript bit code.
When you build your app, you can
actually create a shared
library that runs on the CPU.
And we compile this for sort
of the lowest common
denominator CPU that can
run all the way back to
Gingerbread.
When the app is actually built,
then, the compatibility
library, as well as the shared
libraries for your
RenderScript kernels are
packaged with the app.
And we also package the normal
RS bit code as well.
So on an older device, something
running between
Gingerbread and Android 4.2, we
can use this shared library
that we've built into the app
because it doesn't have API18.
On a suitable device, we can
compile the native bit code
automatically and use whatever
processors or optimizations
are available on that device
without the developer having
to do anything special there.
So what this means, essentially,
is that you can
have one APK that runs on the
Nexus 1 running gingerbread.
And you can take that same APK
and run it on the Nexus 10.
And on the Nexus 1, it'll run
using the CPU shared library.
It will run the CPU, and run
as fast as possible there.
And on the Nexus 10, we'll
compile the bit code for A15.
Use whatever A15 optimizations
we can.
We'll use the GPU, and it'll
run a lot faster.
And so now for the first
time, you can do all
that from one APK.
And with that, I'm going to turn
it over to Jason Sams,
who's going to go through
application.
JASON SAMS: Thanks, Tim.
My name is Jason Sams.
I'm the tech lead for
RenderScript script on
Android, and I'm going to take
us through a simple example of
using RenderScript.
And then we're actually going
to follow up with a more
complex example.
So, the examples we're going
to use are going to be a
Gaussian Blur and a histogram.
So for anyone who attended the
talk yesterday that Rowan and
Chet gave, you may have noticed
that they were talking
about doing drop shadows
using RenderScript.
And I'm actually going to talk
about the primitive they're
using to do this.
RenderScript has been optimized
for doing image
processing tasks.
We've been tuning it for
this workload for a
couple years now.
It's getting pretty
good at it.
The intrinsics that Tim
talked about include a
Gaussian Blur intrinsic.
And so for blurring images
or applying other simple
operations to bitmaps, it's
actually extremely easy to do
that, and that's why we'll walk
through that example.
Histogram will demonstrate
some of the more advanced
techniques.
Things I clipped kernel
launches, which
is coming up soon.
The rsSetElementAt, which
Tim was talking about.
And we'll also demonstrate
multipass
processing over a workload.
So general image processing in
RS, and how you go about it.
The code to do this is actually
pretty simple, and
the first thing you'll want to
do in an application, if
you're going to do some use of
RS is you'll want to create a
RenderScript context.
And the first line of our code,
we create this context.
We actually pass the application
context to that.
Now, coming up soon we'll
actually have a few additional
flags you can pass here, one
of which is a debug mode,
which you can pass into your
contacts creation, and it'll
do things like range check
your access and give you
additional warnings, or errors
if it detects something that's
not optimal, or wrong.
But the next step you'll want
to do is actually create one
of those RenderScript
allocations.
And typically if you're doing
image processing, your input's
probably going to be
a bitmap. map.
And so we have a create from
bitmap helper function, which
will actually create an
allocation from a bitmap, and
it'll automatically set the type
and the height and the
width of that allocation to that
of the incoming bitmap.
Now in addition, you can
optionally map that
allocation, and we have
a few usage flags.
Usage shared, it's new,
or upcoming soon.
And it allows us to share the
back end store with the
bitmap, and that avoids a lot of
the copy overhead that you
would normally get if you had
a separate bitmap and
allocation in the older APIs.
Also, usage graphic texture.
If you were going to use this
in combination with RS
sampler, you can set the
flag to enable that.
And usage script just
means we're going to
pass it into a kernel.
Now, this is actually the
default set of flags, so if
you were to weed the flags
off completely, this is
what you would get.
For the output, we're going
to write this to a bitmap.
So we'll create a second
allocation, and I'm going to
leave off the graphics texture
usage, because we're not going
to sample from it.
So we have a bitmap we're going
to work on, and we're
going to apply a large
blur to this.
So after you have your two
allocations, how would you go
about blurring that image?
The first thing I would do is
I would create a variable to
hold the intrinsic script,
that is the blur.
And then I would create
that blur script.
In this case, since it's an
intrinsic, you don't actually
have to provide a dot RS file.
It's built into the system, But
You still need to tell it
what type of data you
want it to work on.
In this case, we're going
to say it's a uchar4.
That's the element
U8 underscore 4.
We support just uchar buffers,
if you had, say, an alpha
channel, or just a
grayscale image.
And now we'll take that script
that we loaded, and we'll
configure it to perform
our blur.
Now, I'm going to first
set of radius.
In this case, we're
going to set it to
a nice, large radius.
20 pixels, so it's going to
be a big blur operation.
And we'll set on that script
the input allocation we
created in the previous slide,
that will act as our input.
And for the blur, we're
going to run it.
We're just going to call
it the for each.
Since it's an intrinsic, there
is actually no name provided.
It's just called for each, and
write it to our output
allocation.
And after we have done that,
we need to copy our output
allocation back into
our output bitmap.
Now, with usage shared it's
possible this will be a no op
on some devices, and be
extremely efficient.
And with that, you get
a nice blurred image.
This intrinsic is actually
implemented extremely
efficiently.
So if you have an ARM device,
you get handed to a Neon.
If you have an x86 device,
you get SSE that's been
hand-tuned.
On some devices you'll get
a hand-tuned GPU kernel.
So it really is up to each
device how they implement
this, but the key takeaway is
on each device, it's pretty
much the fastest
possible way to
implement it on that device.
Now for histogram, this
is going to be a
more complex example.
We're going to present an
algorithm that does the
histogram in two passes.
The first pass we'll use a
large number of workers.
The second pass will be a much
smaller summation pass.
We do this because the first
pass, we're breaking the image
up into chunks to build
intermediate sums.
And that allows us to do a
lot of work in parallel.
And we'll for the purpose of
time ignore the actual
rendering pass into how we draw
it on the screen, because
there's a lot of different ways
you could theoretically
render this.
So how would you write
a histogram script?
Now, since we don't have an
intrinsic, I'm actually going
to write a dot RS file.
The first thing I'm going to
do is declare some globals.
In this case they're
going to be an RS
underscore allocation type.
That is just the script
equivalent of the allocation
class on the Java side
that will hold our
input and output data.
I will also attach, since it's
a multipass, an intermediate
buffer that'll hold the sums
from the first pass.
And that buffer will be the
number of steps, meaning how
many threads I'm going to run to
do the summations, and 256
units wide, one for each
level of the histogram.
And we'll also have a final sum
buffer, which will just be
a one dimensional allocation
of 256 different levels.
So, additional globals we're
going to pass in will have
just integers that will
represent the height and width
of the input image.
And we will have an integer
which will represent how many
steps, or how many items is in
each step of the image, and
how many steps are in total.
So the kernel for the first
pass, and I'll have a diagram
of how this works in a moment.
What this is going to do is
it's going to walk over a
number of scan lines
in the image.
However many scan lines
will be determined
by the steps value.
Typically you're going to see
values like two or four.
I tried experimentally, a number
of different steps
value, and it's very hardware
dependent what the most
efficient value is.
But you can actually pick values
that worked across a
very large range of hardware.
And we're going to actually
run this kernel.
So you see it takes an x and
y-coordinate, because it's
running on a 2D input image.
But when we watch the kernel
from the Java side, we're
actually going to clip it so
that it only iterates over x
equals 0 and walks through the
different y-coordinates.
I'll go over how we
do that in a bit.
So the first thing we do for
each of these histogram worker
threads is we're going to want
to clear our output of
accumulation buffers.
And I do that just by walking
through a simple loop that
sets the sums buffer.
It sets our particular line, and
then we just loop over the
256 elements.
So, continuing our first pass.
After we've cleared our
accumulation buffer, we'll
need to iterate over
our image.
And we do this for 0 to
the number of scan
lines in our step.
Then we calculate which
wine we're working on.
That's the PY variable.
And if steps is not equally
divisible by the number of
lines in the image, it's
possible we'll need to check
for an overrun here.
So we'll return in that case,
because we'll be done.
And then we walk through
one scan line.
So we just iterate in the kernel
from left to right, and
we'll get an element from our
input image and load that into
a temporary uchar4 value.
We then calculate a luminance
value from that.
In this case, it's just
the integer math.
Nothing terribly exciting.
And then after we've calculated
a luminance value,
we use that is the x-coordinate
index into our
intermediate buffer, and we
load the existing value,
increment it by one, and then
you set [INAUDIBLE]
to write it back.
And this is how we're constantly
accumulating from
each work item and
output value.
So for the second pass, after
the first pass, we have
basically an image which a
number of temporary buffers
that indicate however many
values of each level were run
for that threat.
Now we need to sum all those
together and get one set of
results, not n sets
of results.
This kernel is a 1D kernel, so
it's only going to operate
over one dimension.
And we just simply loop over
within that kernel the input
values, and sum up one vertical
column of levels.
And we return the sum, and that
writes the output value
for that level.
So, rescale.
This is an example of an
invokable function.
So after we have our buffer that
has 256 items and tells
you how many pixels of each
level it saw, what you may
want to do is actually rescale
that to some range.
In this case we'll have
an invokable.
If you notice, there's no
decoration kernel on this.
And it's going to be called
single threaded.
This is good for very small
workloads where you don't want
to necessarily launch a lot
of threads and do a lot of
overhead for a very small
amount of work.
So we loop over, we find the
maximum value in terms of any
one bucket, and then we just
integrate over our buckets,
and we divide the values there
by the greatest value to
effectively normalize
the range.
So what does this look like
on the Java side?
So you've written this
dot RS file.
What do you actually do with
it in terms of interfacing
that with your application?
Well, the first thing you
need to do is load it.
The first line here
is how we do that.
We create a script variable, and
then we can just say new
script C underscore whatever
the name of
your dot RS file is.
And this works because we've
reflected a Java file from
your dot RS file, and
effectively you now have a
Java class with all the methods
that you could use to
actually talk to that
dot RS file.
And so after it's loaded, things
like the width and the
height, those globals, you can
just actually call Java
methods, and it will
set those for you.
You can set any value you want
at that point, but in this
case we'll set the width.
Now
We, need to create the
allocations to hold our data.
We demonstrated earlier how you
would create the input and
output allocations for the
input image and the final
image, but how do you create
those intermediate buffers?
In this case, we're going to
have to do it by building a
custom type, because it's
going to be shaped very
specific to that intermediate
buffer.
So we create a type builder.
We specify an element of INT
32, which is just regular
integer is our element type.
And then we set the x and y
dimensions that we want, in
this case, 256 wide
by steps high.
We create a type from that.
That's the dimensions
of the allocation.
And then we actually allocate
the back end store from that.
So we'll also need to create
that 1D buffer to hold the
final histogram.
And in this case, we'll
again choose INT.
But we have a helper function so
that you don't necessarily
have to create a type for every
allocation you want to create.
If it's a 1D allocation, we
actually have a helper
function that will automatically
create
a 1D type for you.
In this case, 256 elements.
And then we set those
allocations we just created to
the script.
So, running the first pass.
Now, launching scripts from
Java, very straightforward.
But we're going to do something
a little more
complicated than we talked
about in the blur.
If you remember when we talked
about the first paths, we said
we're going to clip this kernel
so that it only ran on
x equals zero, but actually
iterated over all the y's.
So coming soon we have on the
Java side, a new option for
launching kernels, and the
ability to clip the kernel to
the region of interest
that you want that
kernel to run on.
This is very useful if you want
to either do what I'm
about to do here, or if you're
just editing part of an image.
We create a launch option
structure, and then
we set the x range.
The first value's inclusive, the
second value's exclusive,
so that's why you see 0 to 1.
And then we do our for each
pass, and coming soon, not
only can you specify the input
or output allocation, but we
actually reflect overloaded
versions of this that will
take the launch options,
if you so choose.
And so what does this actually
look like running?
So we have the allocation
we created.
The kernel's going
to an each time C
x-coordinate equals zero.
And it's going to see a
y-coordinate that is the
number of steps, as
we drew earlier.
Now, running the second pass.
So after you run the first pass,
the output will be in
that intermediate buffer.
And you can just immediately
call the for each on pass two,
and this will sum the first
buffer into the second, and
now you have a single
allocation, which contains
your range of values.
And we can simply call
re-scale by invoke.
If you notice, this
doesn't take any
parameters in this example.
Invoke functions are actually
very useful for
things like set up.
So if in the dot RS file, you
put some parameters in the
prototype for that function,
you can actually pass them
directly here.
However, you cannot
return values.
So the prototype always
must be void.
And you have your histogram.
So with that, I'm going to open
it up to questions, if
Tim would join us again.
Thanks, everyone.
One other comment, during office
hours I actually have
both an ARM and x86 device that
can be seen running this
example, if anyone's curious.
But it runs very well
on both devices.
The good news here is by writing
in the agnostic code,
we actually generate back end
code that is optimal for all.
Hello.
Take the first question?
AUDIENCE: So you had mentioned
two things.
You mentioned that the ISP and
DSPs, so that's the mobile
devices, is there any access to
the fixed function hardware
like the fast resizing, the fast
color space conversion
you see on ISPs?
And then my second question
was are there any plans to
have RenderScript run on
something other than Android?
Even if it's Chromebooks, or
just regular old Linux.
JASON SAMS: OK, I'll go ahead
and answer the first one.
The answer is yes.
Part of the reason we have
intrinsics is we can use
processors that are more fixed
function than you can by
writing code directly from
a dot RS, or dot FS file.
And so something like the
Gaussian Blur we used as an
example, we actually have other
intrinsics like involved
3x3 and 5x5, those will run very
well on something like a
fixed function ISP or DSP.
Another example that's our YUV
to RGB conversion, again, you
should be able to take advantage
of that fixed
function hardware, because
it's going to be both
extremely power efficient,
and usually very fast.
I'll let you take
the second one.
TIM MURRAY: So as far as other
platforms, it's possible.
Basically during my spare time
in the last six months or so,
I ported this two CUBE
standard Linux.
It just runs on the CPU, but it
was really straightforward,
because we make such heavy use
of LLVM and Clang, essentially
we can port trivially to any
platform that has an LLVM and
Clang, good LLVM and
CLang support.
So in an upcoming AOSP release,
you'll see all sorts
of ifdefs for things
like RS server.
And if you wanted to construct
your own MIG file with an
appropriate version of LLVM
and Clang, you could
certainly do that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering when the API
18 RenderScript stuff gets
into the compatibility
package.
Will that include the
script intrinsics?
JASON SAMS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Easy question.
Oh, follow up.
Is there any time
frame for that?
JASON SAMS: No.
TIM MURRAY: No.
JASON SAMS: You can't
trick us.
AUDIENCE: So just to confirm,
the Gingerbread stuff is
dependent upon 18 coming out.
And then the compatibility
library
will have that, correct?
TIM MURRAY: Correct.
AUDIENCE: OK, follow up is what
memory constraints are
there for the size of the
RenderScript kernels
that you can build?
TIM MURRAY: What do you
mean by the size?
AUDIENCE: Byte code size, like
how big of function or sets of
functions can you build for
might be hitting memory issues
in your device dependent,
or things that you
have seen in the wild?
JASON SAMS: I've seen an entire
H264 encoder written in
RenderScript, so the size
limits are pretty high.
TIM MURRAY: Yeah, I don't think
you'll run into too many
issues with code size.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Mark.
I would like to know, like, more
from the graphical side
of Android, so they are really
high, dedicated examples of
doing graphics in
Windows script.
Like for example, the page
flipping in the ebook reader,
and in the YouTube app, and I
guess the cover flow and the
play music is also done
with Windows script.
Have you thought of building
a website with really high,
dedicated examples with
Windows script?
TIM MURRAY: So we are trying to
improve our documentation
and improve our samples.
In API [INAUDIBLE] you'll see
a lot of new and kind of
hopefully clearer
documentation.
Samples we are working on, in
general, one of hte best
places to look right now, we
have a test called image
processing.
You can find that in ALSP.
That has a lot of different
kernels, and can basically
give you a good idea of how
to write a RenderScript
application.
AUDIENCE: So, no website
available with great examples
here, just the examples
in the SDK?
TIM MURRAY: Yeah, most likely.
I mean, that's where we're
focusing for now.
AUDIENCE: You said you're not
going to support anything
other than the CPU
on Gingerbread.
Is there a technical reason
you can't do that?
I mean, there are a lot
of usable phone DSPs.
TIM MURRAY: Yeah, so essentially
we would need a
new driver on there, and the way
we have our driver work is
we're an OS component.
And the way we can get around
that on the compatibility
library is by loading these
shared libraries, which,
they're not OS components.
So essentially, if we were to
try to support anything more
than the CPU on Gingerbread,
they would have to update that
part of their OS.
AUDIENCE: So is there no way to
get access to, say, like,
TIDSP or anything like that?
TIM MURRAY: Not on
Gingerbread, no.
JASON SAMS: The support
necessarily in the OS simply
wasn't there in Gingerbread, so
there's really nothing we
can do without an OS update.
OK, thanks everyone.
I think we're out of time, so
will be around for office
hours if anyone has additional
questions.